this is Startalk this is Startalk and
I'm your host your personal
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson I
work at the American Museum of Natural
History right here in New York City
where I also serve as director of the
Hayden Planetarium and for this episode
of Startalk we're doing what we call
cosmic queries where questions come to
me from our social media and but I don't
read the I don't even I don't even know
what they are until I walk in and sit
down at this microphone and I get help
today
from Chuck nice hey Neil what's
happening yeah ah good to be here man
and welcome back thank you thank you sir
always good to be so you you do you
gonna breed what are these questions
what's today's topic today's topic is
the space race okay I think I know a
little bit about that but actually just
so you know this may sound like a cheap
plug but it's just so I wrote a book
called space chronicles right facing the
ultimate frontier came out two years ago
do you know why I write books because
you can and I know my limitations know I
write books so that I never have to talk
about that subject again really compiled
it all in there and someone should tell
me about the handbook yeah and I go and
I walk away my god so so I you know you
just you're resurrecting this in me when
I'm trying to think about other stuff
but fine sorry I'm sorry to do that oh
my god I can't believe he just said that
that you write a book so you don't have
you remind me say that this is the
household I grew up in this woman so I
would ask my mother or my father what
does this mean and they would say go
look it up
whoa whoa I'm like yeah that's what
you're for so what may have looked like
evil parents at the day turned it turned
you into an independent researcher
actually yeah I'm kind of I'm cut and
now it's funny because I do the same
thing to my children they're like you
know my son he'll say dad do you know
and I'm like yeah I do know do you
we'll find out and cut that so that
works whether or not you actually know
it all right let's do our cosmic queries
and of course we always start off with
the patreon patron question and if you
support us on patreon we will give your
questions priority here at cosmic
queries okay okay where we basically buy
your loyalty okay here we go
Matthew Macedon from Calgary Alberta hmm
says in your opinion dr. Tyson what was
the most significant thing that the
Apollo program achieved with the
exception of landing on the moon wow
that's oh that's a good question when
you think about it cuz everybody you say
Apollo program it's moon landing bang
that's the end of it that's it but he's
saying give me something that is just as
significant that we don't think about
dang so beginning in 1970 a little
earlier but in 1970 was the first Earth
Day nationally and then it became a
rapid international hit if you will
because Earth Day is global man is
global now and it's a significant global
celebration of our home planet and
around that same time so night to
whatever what else happened nineteen
seventy one two and three we would see
the passing of the comprehensive Clean
Air Act Clean Water Act in 1970 NOAA was
founded the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration to monitor
our climate and our oceans and our
weather and not only that the
Environmental Protection Agency was
founded in 1970 by the time 1973 came
around leaded gas would be banned did
leaded gas would be banned DDT would be
banned the catalytic converter would be
introduced all of this happened during
the years we were going to the moon at a
time when we had a whole lot of other
stuff distracting us like a coal
or with the Soviet Union in a hot war in
Southeast Asia and campus unrest from
anti-war protests and the civil rights
movement and assassinations in 1968
would see two assassinations on domestic
soil and so so why am I saying all this
because while we had all these other
potential distractions we nonetheless
paused to reflect on our relationship to
our home planet
so I submit to you that though we went
to the moon liked to explore the moon
upon getting there and looking back in
fact we would discover earth for the
first time Wow so it's like I've been to
paradise but I've never been to me it's
exactly that so can you put a dollar
figure right on the fact that seeing
earth in the sky from the moon was like
a firmware update in our sense of
awareness and who we are of the
importance of Earth and our relationship
to it right okay that's that's actually
that's a bit more existential than I was
expecting for an answer okay I have to
say it's a damn good answer because it's
more of the the it's more of a
collective conscious enlightenment yes
and I don't think anyone started the
program with that expectation right but
that is clearly a consequence of it and
so and remember that TV commercial with
the Native Americans standing on this on
the and was a tear in his eye a tear
the single tear went and people throwing
garbage out through it that didn't
happen until this period till we were
going to the moon we were total garbage
out the window people for long before
that right never got that about us that
means seriously garbage out the window
pretty much all through human history
all through human history and the fact
that was great for anthropologists they
can find stuff along the Roman
you know that people Oh with McDonald's
Cup or McDonald's would have been around
no but you you it was we didn't start
thinking of it as a as a cause a
cultural environmental problem until
that that period Wow okay
wow that's a hey Matthew I you know I
hope you're satisfied with that answer
because it was a completely curved
complete curveball with that answer
and then there's tang that and Tang a
close second there you go all right okay
here we go our next question huh Oh
Abhijit money mm-hmm let's hope I'm
sorry abba sheet i'm sorry from facebook
wants to know this the space race was in
a way an extension of the Cold War arms
race but also the resolve of president
john f kennedy who pledged that we get
there in ten years do you know anyone
today in the political sphere who could
do the same what kind of politician
would be ideal in this regard we go to
the moon because we choose tool it's
that and the other thing we do because
never forget it
check out your worst impression it
really is normally your good no but you
know I'm not even doing Kennedy I'm
actually doing mayor Quimby's you know
Walt Quimby you imitate a TIE fighter
from Star Wars
I thought Kennedy would be easy we have
to after that yes so so here's there's
an assumption built into that question
that the political will and charisma
perhaps of Kennedy was a significant
force operating in how and why we got to
the moon and this is commonly thought
but I I'm contrarian in that regard
well good right no doubt Kennedy had
charisma no doubt he had a sort of way
with rallying people behind an idea no
doubt about that but I submit that if we
were not at war all that would have just
been empty rhetoric and nobody would
have signed the check cut Congress
because Congress is not as swayed by
speeches as the public is absolutely all
right then so it's Congress who writes
the check that's right at the end of the
day
so consider 1989 the 20th of July 20th
the 20th anniversary of the moon landing
who is the then sitting president I
don't know whether Bert Walker
George Herbert Walker Bush George Harvey
goes to the steps of the Air and Space
Museum delivers a speech not
fundamentally different from Kennedy
speech we're Americans we're explorers
Columbus set sail this is our time we
will put men on Mars and have a space
station who have us build a space
station and we will this he was trying
to give a Kennedy speech right okay
fell flat on his face now why people
Sybil because he's not Kennedy I beg to
differ
okay not that he isn't not Kennedy right
listen well he isn't Kennedy it didn't
work not because he isn't Kennedy right
I claim it didn't work because do you
remember what happened in 1989 I don't
know piece broke out at least broke out
in Europe that's a terrible thing that
is the collapse of the Soviet empire
it's right that is the tear down the
wall the wall came down in 1989 all of a
sudden our motivation for our military
might the very thing that drove who and
what we were as the carriers of freedom
and the American Way in in the face of
evil communists it all evaporated ah
that year and he's trying to give a
speech to get people to go to Mars in
the absence of a mortal enemy right so
we would have either needed Martians
that'd be the best could have been the
best the best right we either need a
Martian evil Martians evil Martians
yeah we're not yet what a [ __ ] came
out guns drawn awesome he shot Elliott
or whatever the hell that that's the way
it ends I mean we must test our ray guns
right yeah so really they a competition
no competition no it's not only
competition because you can do that and
yes and still succeed but the greatest
competition our species knows is the
threat of death from someone who might
out-compete you in a way that would kill
you so I claim that the biggest reason
that failed was not because Bush lacked
the charisma of Kennedy what happened is
he lacked the Cold War right and by the
way he proposed you know what it was you
know once he said this will be a 25 year
I forgot the exact time interval 25
years plan and and it would be you know
25 30 year plan and it'll cost a
trillion dollars whoa okay so people
freaked right then that was the end of
that right there or or half a trillion
dollars half a trillion dollars alright
okay we can work with that here's the
thing if you took NASA's budget at the
time which is between 15 and 20 billion
dollars in today's the annual budget and
then you multiply that over 30 years
right you get half a trillion all in
dollars so we already are allocating
half a trillion dollars to NASA over
that same amount of time right so to say
that's DOA because it's too much money
that's a false argument right
NASA was all might have to retool NASA
with its budget but it was a false
argument to think it's too much money
that's all so so so I'm unconvinced by
people saying that George Herbert Walker
Bush was absent the charisma of Kennedy
so so I mean I don't so I don't Lee has
anything to do with politicians right so
do with whether we think we're gonna die
okay and there you have it by the way
just to let you know if you are gonna
die so we should we should do it
irrespective
I think that if we really want to go to
Mars died by unnatural causes there you
go
if we really want to go to Mars we
should we scientists should get together
and in an in a at this in a somewhat
conspiratorial way tell the world that
there's oil on Mars yes but then we be
we be lying yeah but we go to Mars do
you know why there's terrorists on Mars
so why this oil on earth because we have
life on Earth right and but so maybe
okay maybe there's a period there's an
episode of Mars where there was life
right well that life sunk down and then
it made oil so that'd be cool elliptical
it Mars and get oil and we'd be there
next week look what I what I joke about
is what we should go to China and go go
tell the leaders of China can you leak a
memo then don't be true it have to be
true just leak a memo say you want to
put military bases on mom that's it deal
we're done
there you go we're on Mars there are
Mars in ten months seven months one
month it's fun design build the
spacecraft nine months to get there we
go to Mars not because it is easy but it
because it is hard and the time ease
once again awful awful impersonation
mmm-hmm all right let's move on well
that's a that's pretty cool I agree with
what you're saying it's not about I
think people put too much emphasis on
the importance of the presidency and
they're unaware of how much power the
president really has our whole system
Lazar does not have right our whole
system of government is designed to keep
power out of the hands of the president
Greece Iceland a president doesn't run
away like a dictator right right right
so you know people often overestimate
what the president can and cannot do
exactly you know oh cool let's move on
to for a couple more questions okay in
this segment here we go
Isaac Jacob of Facebook thank you Isaac
Isaac has a pronounceable name Thank You
Isaac
from NYC this is what Isaac says
hometown boy that's right what kind of
computing power did Mission Control and
the shuttle have during the Apollo era
yeah I can only tell you what I've read
about that because I didn't like
calculate this myself but there have
been comments that the computing
or I don't believe this but it was fun
to read it and say it the computing
power of a singing greeting card no
there's a chip in there - laughs open it
up the happy birthday to that that's
happy birthday Duke
so so I may it had to have been a little
more than that and I don't I don't know
the answer for sure because again I
don't know these questions but I could
have researched it of course before you
don't die questions I don't get the
question but what is no doubt no doubt
anything we're carrying in our hip
pocket is greater than anything that was
going on when we went to the moon wait a
minute now okay I do believe that
because of the micro processors that we
use in order to run our phone by the way
but by the way right by the way the
miniatures ation of electronics right is
entirely driven in its initial stages by
NASA okay we had electronics filling you
know so our parents our grandparents yes
had radios the size of furniture in
their living room or at where they would
gather round and listen to radio show
listen to radio shows and was any of
them saying gee I want to carry this on
my hip it's just an on thought right
that doesn't mean they might not welcome
it but no one is even thinking that way
like that you're right
NASA is saying we need this technology
and we need to launch it and it cost
$10,000 a pound to put anything in orbit
so we got to shrink this break this down
yeah just shrink it down as to the lab
and shrink it down right now okay so
this this miniaturization drives a whole
frontier that then then becomes
commercial commodities absolutely I just
had it's fascinating what you just said
because about grandparents and radio
sitting around the radio listening to
their programming yeah when I was a kid
we sat around the television I never
once thought I want to carry that
television on my hip never could guess
what I do my phone it's a freaking
television I can watch the internet or
any TV show I want on demand all my
phone I am carrying a TV on my hip
exactly amazing yeah that is so cool and
if you don't think about it
TV is the thing you do when you get home
and you turn it on right right right
yeah but no longer yeah
oh man that's super cool so so basically
I would say yeah so do you remember in
the movie Apollo 13 you're trying to
save the guys lives and they said here
is the only thing they have available
they dumped out this bag onto the table
okay Engineers save their lives and they
said okay but wait a minute I did so it
oh we need this the slide rule so so
anyhow yeah yes so you would blow it
away so back then computers were used
for timing things and simple simple and
simple calculations and the rest was
very mechanical okay but that back one
lose the right stuff right yeah now the
right stuff is all in a computer we got
a break when we come back we'll have
more cosmic queries from you on the past
present and future of space exploration
we're back on Startalk and I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist with me my co-host Chuck
nice that's right doing cosmic queries
yes we are Sarah base exploration that's
right that's from Facebook and Twitter
and the fan base of Startalk everywhere
they are we went and asked and they
asked that and they're coming back
that's good and I haven't seen these
questions before so I did of my
ignorance if I don't but I did publish a
book on this subject yes but we'll
forgive your ignorance thoughts on this
matter in the first segment you asked me
very clean intelligent questions we know
crazy questions out there don't worry I
okay we got some crazy questions here
all right okay since you said that I'm
gonna get right in me in this minute but
fine you know what I'm glad you brought
it up cuz it's staring me right in the
face and I honestly wasn't gonna ask you
this so Sean Thomas from facebook says
this have you ever punched someone in
the face like buds often did yes why did
you do that
if No well who would you like to
so I added the last part okay so what's
the person's name again Sean Sean Thomas
Sean is is remembering an incident where
cuz because Buzz Aldrin the second man
to walk on the moon by the way he landed
on the moon in the same instant that
Neil Armstrong did yes during the same
damn spacecraft and then they played
rock paper scissors and some other guy
actually won so you know I was called a
scissor paper stone paper scissors
scissors paper stone you truly are a
geek who's ever heard of scissor paper
stone I know I that's how I've learned
it but Rakesh you're fine fine rock
paper scissors
all right so I'm gonna start calling it
scissor paper stone now just to get a
reaction from people suzer paper silicon
dioxide scissor Paras silicon dioxide
Pyro's right so that was the question
okay have you ever seen somebody please
I don't have I ever have you ever
personally inconstant Lee be accosted by
people saying we didn't go to the moon
and can he prove it will he swear on a
Bible that he went to the moon as nobody
ever lies with their hand on the Bible
we know that from every single court
case in history put your hand on that
Bible oh you got me I murdered her okay
so he did they put his hand on the Bible
gosh I gotta tell you had the glove on
so he wasn't touching the Bible actually
nice nice with the gloves nice like like
so and and apparently there's a youtube
video that shows him punching a guy now
buzz was badass in his day he you know
was a pole vaulter I did not know that
yeah if you're a pole vaulter muscles in
all the right places let me tell you
this you today so so it was like 80 not
we had a monster on Startalk I've
actually met him through you okay yes so
by the way still a surly like guy who
and I shouldn't say surly still a
vibrant vibrant it's got energy for life
yeah thinking exactly and so he so
there's this video of him punching a guy
out
now I didn't really believe the video
and then I asked him and he denied it
that didn't mean he didn't feel like
doing it at times right let's assume
this is what he feels like doing whether
or not he did do it right so the real
question is do I ever feel like punching
someone in the face for not believing
that we went landed on the moon and I
don't feel compelled to harm people in
their ignorance oh that's very kind
no no I don't mean ignorant in a bad way
this just I know do you mean you're
saying and that's very compassionate of
you you're saying that you look at a
person and you will sympathize because
they're in their ignorance yes I'm an
educator educator so you want to help
that person you see a person in need
when you see an ignorant person yes I
see a dummy now is the difference
between me I see someone there was a
there's a gap in their education and
people think that education is just what
you know right no no no no no yeah
that's an aspect of it but for me the
most important element of Education is
what is your capacity to think awesome
and so what leaves you in denial that we
went to the moon right why are you
what's the resistance here and and look
at everything else you do embrace
they're probably using a cell phone a
smartphone that's communicating with
satellites so we can put a satellite up
there cell phones out so I don't
understand why this was such a stretch
to imagine and and and why would we not
go to the moon
nine times okay well there you have it
right then stop not going to the moon
exactly because if it were a fraud that
we perpetuated when we still be
perpetuating that fraud but just a
little further out little bro I mean why
not and then so so someone did the count
did the analysis what would it take to
fake the moon landing okay so you'd have
to think all of the buildings where
you're where you're constructing the
spaceships the spacecraft right look at
Saturn five atom fire and you'd have to
you'd you would have to fake all the
engineering drawings the
we're houses of engineering drawings
right and you'd have to fake the you
know the docking and all this
communication and and by the time you
figure out what it takes to fake it it's
way easier just to go certainly yes will
you put it that way it's why just go to
the moon you know what and that's very
much it's funny because people who think
like that I call that the criminal
mentality mmm I call it the genius
criminal mentality nemesis mentality the
nemesis mentality if you took half the
energy that you put into doing what you
are doing that is wrong into doing
something constructive you would be very
successful yes you wouldn't be sitting
in prison right now you'll be running
you'd be CEO of whatever cut ever you
beat Tony Stark you'd be Tony Stark
looks like some of these guys they come
up with genius ways to do the wrong
thing but because they have this
criminal mentality and it screws them
there's a synapse firing in the wrong
wrong they went the wrong fork in this
in exactly yeah you know and you're
right it's like when you think about
everything first of all the other thing
too is when you see these Rockets take
off we aren't they going
no it's you can calculate how much fuel
is in a Saturn five rocket in all three
stages and I assure you they were not
going to the Piggly Wiggly down the
street this is enough fuel to get them
to the moon and back you keep if it's
not intro calculus a little later you
can learn what's called the rocket
equation okay and you can derive it and
know what it is and the rocket equation
prescribes how much fuel you need that's
how much fuel was in the Saturn five
rocket that's it
so but I have it I take a slightly other
view of this I think wow they are so
impressed with modern technology that
they're in denial of it Wow that's how
far we've come see you really are a
capacity you truly are like and I tell
you it's funny because you know you know
people ask me all the time about you you
know but they're like what's meal really
like and I tell them Neil is exactly
like what you see and he truly is when
people call him the world's foremost
science educator that is like his
singular focus in life like you know
people who have a singular foe
like yours and at every turn I see you
take the time to Lex Luthor Lex Luthor
has a singular singular focus except
instead of like ruling the world you
it's to educate the world right no I
just want people to be empowered and
then I go home I'll go back to the to
the beach and I'll stand call me if you
need me but once you're empowered you
don't have to keep coming back to me
write this thing for your own damn self
that makes perfect sense I mean I don't
get it I think it's people people are in
denial of that that that kind of thing
because they just want a government
conspiracy
they love them some governments love
government cuz anyone who's worked for
the government said we are incapable of
a conspiracy
yeah we are not organized enough we're
not conspire anything it's never
government workers saying we're we're
we're arias why someone who's worked
their life in the government and asked
them if they could ever possibly offer
conspiracy they can ever possibly hide
alien at the front desk
that's hilarious
okay hey there you go so on Thomas we
ate up half the name figure on that
question but it was funny it was good it
was good to know it was good to know so
there you have it Shawn the old doesn't
want to punch people in the face he just
wants to educate them so his punch in
the face is knowledge mm-hmm I just
punched you the face with knowledge we
slap you with knowledge also this
reminds me of one of arthur c clarke
edicts which is any sufficiently
advanced technology right is
indistinguishable from magic
you know that absolutely so you think if
so the going of the moon that's advanced
for you exactly
in magic or conspiracy right like if you
took like an oculus back to just let's
say 1925 hmm okay where they're worth
significance was that a leader of Rome
meet my cousin calculus oculus and
calculus say you let's say you oculus
ancient Roman with a British accent
Romans don't think our British every
single Roman father tell me Father
why do you not love me no oculus is that
quartz yeah what I'm saying there give
er the virtual reality trance a virtual
reality if you took that back to 1925
which is at a time where there were
significant advancements in technology
and everything everything I mean you
know we're at that point Einstein had
already had the theory of relativity was
already established at that point if you
put an oculus on somebody back then they
would believe that you were a god yeah
the head would Explorer head would
explode like you could put an oculus on
them and say like by the way I'm from
another planet and they would believe
whatever you say after that and then
they'll say how can we make this do sin
have sex always every new technology
technology that's how that's how I go by
the way they've already figured that out
they just have a new okay I mean we even
have it with cars yeah how do we have
sex in a car you know a whole generation
having been conceived in the backseat of
cars absolutely that's why my Lincoln
[Laughter]
here we go this is Hobbit romic Hobbit
Roenick from Instagram wants to know
this Neil do you pick the amount of
money or time spent going to the moon
multiple times could have been better
spent focusing on other space related
research exploration projects could we
be on Mars by now if we had knocked on
that to the moon several more times
could we have a small-scale orbital
colony somewhere a JIRA a zero-g
manufacturing plant I mean are there
other things he goes on other things
that we could have done most of the
money to get to the moon was to get
there the first time okay yeah after
that it's sort of incremental cost it's
not so so you have to build the
infrastructure to make the Saturn 5
rockets to get the engineers and the
scientists so it's like scaling up for
anything not even unique great as pharma
companies will tell you that the very
first pill is a billion dollars yeah 100
million whatever it is expensive the
second one costs 10 cents to make
exactly so so that's the so really it's
that's not the right way to think about
that problem the right way to think
about it is or I don't want to force
this question to be a make it a
different question because you just
answered that the answer is this don't
scale up that's it
let me morph the questions just be
slightly different so suppose the Apollo
mission was not let's go to the moon but
let's explore space right then we would
then you would have resources not only
going to the moon exploring an asteroid
a comet Mars and you'd be building the
capacity to go to space and then your
destination would be what you would
choose after you have that capacity in
the same way we built the interstate
system of the United States right we
didn't say here's a road from New York
to LA that's the only place you're going
to go and that's it right right if I
want to be creative and I have an idea I
want to do something in Utah
Wyoming or or or Illinois forced me to
go one place and no place else so so I
think it would have been a little better
had there been a broader now others the
rebuttal to that is you have to focus
you need the singular mission otherwise
it'll never get done
right and I get that but if you want to
sustain it forever you want to turn a
space program into a space industry
right you want to turn it into a just a
thing you want to turn this the sky into
your backyard then you want to build the
capacity to go anywhere you want a
continuing mission
continuing mission these are the mats
right that's correct that's right so
once you have a can tell so I think some
of that money might have been better
suited to set up a way to maintain that
mission for space at all and so I agree
that I agree with the sentiment of that
question but I just read read read yeah
but now let me just ask you just click
follow up cuz we're running out of time
on the segment but just as a quick
follow-up do you think the
commercialization of space and the
commodification of space will allow us
to get to where you are talking about
right now it's the commercial lace and
the commodification space which is
what's happened that will do isn't all
that drop the price of going to space to
the point where other creative things
you can think of doing in space become
real alright so that that's the
fascinating thing when things get
cheaper like all ideas pop up you would
have never thought possible
okay so so if going in space is cheap I
can't even imagine what more we can
think of doing in space but it is surely
there because it happens every other
time anything gets cheap so so yes
that'll happen the frontier space is a
different thing I don't see that I don't
see because there's no money and there's
no money in that yeah no business model
to do that okay right
but once we once that routine is set up
oh yeah okay yeah right we got a break
when we come back we will continue with
Chuck nice reading me cosmic queries on
the frontier space exploration we're
back on
Startalk I got check nice with me yes
you do sir this is cosmic queries
edition that's correct this is a
fan-favorite cosmic queries yeah people
love this you know why because this is
the thing that we do on Startalk that
belongs solely to the fans yeah it
really is that's it it's their show it's
really you know we're just here as a
conduit to carry out their whim so I
shouldn't tell them that I really don't
like doing rather just sit there and let
someone else do the talking making me
talk making me work hard so alright
before we gonna check with yes um so
you're still doing stand-up with all the
time pretty much everything you know so
here's the thing I don't travel as much
to on the road which I get a lot of
requests but two reasons one I have a
small and so I'd like to be home and bit
more than one child I have one of them
smaller one of us very small because I'm
an idiot and we just had a new baby two
years ago that's a new baby like there's
such a thing as a whole we had an old
baby we had all my years ago I gave
birth to Benjamin Button anyway and the
but I always do stand-up in New York
City and surrounding area pretty much
every weekend I love your work just and
that's why we have you here to expand I
always love being firm that all right so
what do you got okay let's get back into
our queries Aidan astronomy from
Instagram says cerana me is in his
handle I see this I love dad like that
but loving the universe and they can't
help not tell I gotta let people know so
he says what was it like for the command
module pilots when they went around the
back side of the moon and why did the
Soviet n1 moon rockets all blow up so
and instead of what was it like let me
just say on the back side of the moon
what are you experiencing on the back
side of the Moon that you're not
experiencing on the front side - so
first first as you may remember the
Apollo missions all sent three
astronauts to the moon two of them
deployed down to the surface one did not
right stayed in orbit around the moon
eating their lunch waiting for them
finished driving a golf cart that are
known as the uber driver of Apollo so
I'm wondering if I would have just snuck
in and then crammed three people into
the lander and and you know I don't know
you're gonna go travel that far and just
not have to sit in a ma wait in the car
we'll be right out we're gonna walk
around on the moon walk around the moon
do me a favor can you just keep the car
running leave the conference car running
buddy
we're just gonna take a little stroll on
the moon on the moon yeah so here's the
thing when you go to the back side of
the moon
you are one moon diameter away from the
other two astronauts okay okay okay
that is the record for the loneliest
person ever oh that's so cool because
you're just farther out then you're
farther away by yourself next closest
person right in that moment is one moon
diameter a web that is farther than any
other solo person has been Wow yes right
so that's just one little fact that is
the loneliest place we have ever found
ourselves ah yeah that's pretty cool
little what makes it toy what makes it
extra lonely is when you're behind the
moon right then the moon is between you
and Earth right and the radio signals
don't penetrate through the moon so you
also radio silent oh my god alone and
alone yes you're double alone or double
a long cut alone squared right you can't
communicate with anybody either correct
this is why in the future when we're
thinking of moon colonies and you want
to inhabit the far side of the Moon the
far side never faces earth okay the moon
is its rotation is what's called tidally
locked right where it's actually
rotating but at the exact rate that it
takes to go around the earth right it
was always turning it's one face towards
you no matter where it is
it's cold it happens it's a very natural
thing in the universe right don't think
too much about it okay yeah I'm thinking
about it
let me say something my gosh what a
coincidence is that just for us do that
okay Layton it's a natural thing okay so
so so when we're thinking about moon
colonies if you're gonna pitch tent on
the far side of the Moon you're gonna
still want communication channels opened
up right so there's a whole separate
conversation about radio transmitter
repeaters that are on the edge of the
Moon where signals can come from the
back side and then work their way back
over to the front side and then make its
way back they say you send the signal to
the booster the booster sends it exactly
exactly and so it's a repeater whatever
whatever is the mechanism right so so
hear me now let me move over here let me
now how's that Jesus I'm roaming I'm
sorry I'm on the moon this is costing me
a fortune
okay sorry can I give it like a weirdly
perverse version of that okay so I was
on a Presidential Commission okay to
study the the the climate of aerospace
around the world relative to here on
earth climate I mean the business
climate right and so in one of our trips
we go to China and China has these have
they've got plans to go to space alright
this before they launch their first I
cannot okay which is what they call
their astronauts antagonize their Tyco
nots and so so there's this this
underbelly of advanced technology that
we're reading about an earring about and
I was wondered you know is it real is it
there so I'm on the Great Wall of China
suite and it there it is just like the
photos going to the horizon into the
mists all right you can't there's no end
in either direction you look I do not
see any technology at all in any there
no antennas there's no nothing made of
metal there is just the wall Wow
and I said let me try something I pull
out my cell phone okay there's a flip
phone at the time I call my attack I
call my it was in fact the Motorola
StarTAC
and I call my because it's good thank
you
come on I called my mother in
Westchester New York she said oh hi Neil
are you home already
that's how good the connection was nice
it was it was crystal clear connection
who certainly didn't have sprint it was
one of the best connections I've ever
had in a cellphone ever from the Great
Wall of China
with no visible cell phone towers and I
then at that time you would walk past a
tree in the United States or so I'm
sorry I lost my signal let me get out in
the open here away from the blades of
grass whatever so so that's how I knew
China was gonna make whatever they want
happen happen Wow a moment that's pretty
wild in that moment that look wait
that's that's actually a very good story
and really telling because it makes
sense right you don't see anything and
it's there why did I even say that I was
supposed to am I related to this
question I'm sorry
now I lost I think I answered the
question sorry what is it know what it
was like for that pilot oh yeah that's
what it was that's exactly what it was
like eating the sandwich waiting just
and by the way I'm gonna say that is the
lonely existence ever not just because
of where he is and not just because of
his isolation but because of the context
of that isolation yes you are alone and
your friends are walking on the moon
it's triple it's like I'm alone I can't
communicate with anybody and I'm keeping
the car warm and they're on the moon yes
getting all the glory all right I
checked time for cosmic queries
lightning round
let's do it I'm gonna give soundbite
answers sound byte and there you go okay
here we go
[Music]
this is different give me somebody
answers you have to read the questions a
little Chrisman era 97 from instagram
what is the biggest thing we learned
from going to the moon or sorry what is
the biggest thing the moon taught us
about earth for me I have a I'm my
personal list of that all right I think
going to the moon and getting direct
measurements of its mineral content and
soil content from
the coolest thing was discovering that
the moon is the product of a collision
between a mars-sized proto planet
outside swiping Earth's crust in the
early solar system having that material
that had been sideswiped gather into
another cosmic body that orbits earth
that we now call the moon the moon for
its size should have much much more iron
in it right but it doesn't the iron has
already somehow been sifted out because
the iron has already been sifted out
well how do you make that happen well on
earth the iron all went to the core and
most of the iron went to the core so the
crust has hardly any iron in it if
you're gonna make a new cosmic object
out of the crust you're gonna have
hardly any iron in your substance so the
moon has suspiciously a low iron and it
is completely consistent with this
scenario nice and and people asked me if
I wanted to go back in time and see
something happen I'd want to see the
collision of that mars-sized proto
planet with earth and watch the moon get
formed we think it would have formed
within a few months that quick guess
that quickly Wow quickly that would be
in a badass yeah that's a nice game you
got okay that was too long I got an
answer faster all right here we go at
seabass 621 wants to know this fisherman
there he's some sea bass all right who
do you think won won the space race oh I
call it a tie the United States and
Russia okay yeah you know why why
because they were the first to put
anything in space a they were the first
to put a living creature in space
they're the first to put a human in
space they were the first to put a woman
in space they were the first to put a
black person in space they're the first
to have a space station they invented
the rocket equation that enabled all
this to happen in the first place and we
went to the moon first you know so okay
so to me I'm saying you know we didn't
do anything other stuff first and we got
too much it we win I'm saying give the
people some credit here please
next that was a great answer all right
since the moon is loaded I'm sorry hey
there black person was a Cuban so Brent
rau Brent rau wants to know this since
the moon is loaded with
helium-3 which is useful for alternative
energy how do you think laws will form
in retaliation to mining the moon mine
the moon nice so helium helium-3 is a
version of helium missing one proton
helium usually has two protons two
neutrons that would be helium four take
away Neutron you get helium three that's
what's called okay helium-3 is one of
the things that is emanated from the Sun
in the solar wind and it comes through
space it gets lodged in the surface of
the Moon and it sits there and there are
whole books given unto mining quite
simply scooping up the topsoil of the
moon collecting this helium-3
and using it for nuclear fusion reactors
so there's a whole plan that people have
for this and there's been some rebuttals
is will it really recoup the cost
whatever so but helium-3 yeah we need
laws going into the future who owns the
moon who owns asteroids who owns the
mining rights do they have to be shared
who paid for it this there are some laws
related to this but for me it's still
undiscovered territory and this is why
the the future in space is not just
about astronauts scientists and
engineers there's the rest of what life
is and lawyers the artists the politics
all of this has to come together if
we're gonna turn what is sitting there
above our head that we call space into
our backyard Wow there you have it
you've been listening to and possibly
even watching Startalk I've been your
host Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist Chuck nice dude thank you
brother always guys thanks for coming
through helping me get through this
cosmic queries and as always I bid you
to keep looking up this is Startalk
you